الحرب في اوكرانيا تفاقم خطرا نووي
الايراني قرار موسكو تعليق روسيا معاهده
نيو ستارت اقلقت تل ابيب من غياب مراقبه
موسكو لفائض اليورانيوم الايراني والقرار
جاء في وقت تقترب طيران من تجاوز الخط
الاحمر بصنع قنبله النوويه يفصلها عن ذلك
فقط 6% بحسب الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه وهذا لتخصيب اليورانيوم سرا لنسبه
وصلت الى 84%
كشف ماثان مشبوه ظهر قبل ذلك تعديل سري في
منشاه بوردو بربط مجموعتين من اجهزه الطرد
المركزي من طراز اي ار 6 لتخصيب
اليورانيوم بعيدا عن اعين المفتشين وكاله
ايران تنفي باسرار رفع درجه التخصيب وتعزو
التقرير مفتشين وكاله بانه اما خاطئ او
مسيس رغم انها اقرت بوجود جزيئات تزيد
نسبه التقسيط فوق الستين في المئه لكن حسب
ما قالوها هذا لا يعني الانتاج بتخصيب
اعلى من هذه النسبه مراقبه هذا التطور
النووي في توجس وفي مقدمتهم اسرائيل
مستشارها للامن القومي خرج لينتقد تعاطي
الوكاله مشيرا الى ان هذه النسبه تثبت ان
البرنامج النووي ليس للاستخدام المدني
وبينما تجري الوكاله ومديرها رفيال جروسي
محادثات مع ايران حول نتائج انشطه التفتيش
الاخيره تدعم واشنطن تل ابيب ضد تهديداتي
ايران
للمنطقه باكملها
[موسيقى]